drôle qu'on parle de 25 ans ça a l'air
d'être beaucoup un quart de siècle
mais pour moi c'est vraiment comme si
c'était hier
les souvenirs sont encore extrêmement
douloureux pour philibert nous y m'a
toujours hanté par l'horreur du génocide
en avril 1994 il avait 24 ans son père
sa mère ses quatre soeurs et deux de ses
frères ont été massacrés par des
génocidaires hutus lui même a failli
être tué tous mes amis tous les tutsis
dans ma région
des milliers des milliers sont morts
j'ai en jambes et leurs cadavres ga
jambes et les blessés qui agonisait qui
m'a demandé de dollars mais je devais
fuir
pour tenter d'échapper à ma propre et
noir je suis le seul survivant de ce
groupe
pourquoi parce que la personne qui
devait moi tu es à résister philibert
nous ima a été grièvement blessé il a
été laissé pour mort au milieu des
cadavres mais il a survécu
il s'est réfugié au canada dans les
années 2000 aujourd'hui il est père de
trois enfants tous nés au canada
il a parfois du mal à mettre des mots
sur cette tragédie
surtout quand sa plus grande lui pose
des questions quand elle m'a posé de
question j'ai dit comment leur compteur
une histoire si horrible à un enfant si
innocent je suis pas formés pour savoir
parler à un enfant comme ça et je me
suis dit c'est le moment que j'écrive le
livre de philibert nous ima imbibé de
leur sens grave et de leur nom est sorti
en 2016
le père de famille a pu mettre des mots
sur l'horreur qu'il a vécu et surtout
raconter à ses enfants qui étaient leurs
grands parents leurs oncles leurs tentes
leurs cousins et cousines assassinés
parce qu'ils étaient tout si quand on
prête à la guerre mais j'ai déjà
commencé un peu il ya quelques années
puis même survolé les images qu'ils sont
est-ce que dedans c'est vraiment j'ai
l'impression que je suis capable
d'imaginer comment il était plus fait
comment sa famille et et puis je suis
capable de consentir une connexion je
comprends qu'ils devaient paix corée
pour leur vie et qui en a plusieurs
démêlés qu'ils ont été assassinés et
puis que y'en a beaucoup de ma famille
aussi
[Musique]
les deux filles de philibert musi ma
joue d'ailleurs dans une pièce de
théâtre écrite pour commémorer le
génocide
une façon pour elle de mieux comprendre
cette sombre page d'histoire à travers
l'art marie rose est la fille du
président rwandais juvénal habyarimana
qui a été tué lorsque son avion a été
abattu par un tir de missile le 6 avril
94 pour elle le deuil est encore
extrêmement difficile marie-rose réclame
depuis 25 ans qu'on traduise les
coupables de cet attentat devant la
justice 25 ans plus tard nous c'est vrai
bien sûr que la plaie encore ouverte et
nous a pas permis de faire notre deuil
on n'a pas fait notre deuil on n'a pas
pu enterrer notre perle dignement
on nous reconnaît pas le statut de
victime les commémorations prévues
dimanche feront une large place à la
nouvelle génération porteuse d'espoir
c'est un sujet très délicat dans le
cercle des rondes et c'est justement la
discussion chaque fois de se dire
comment est ce qu'on peut transmettre la
mémoire sans transmettre la haine
évidemment ça prend un travail d'abord
individuelle au niveau des parents au
niveau des adultes parce que la plupart
des fois c'est ce message que vous
transmettez à l'enfant qui va être le
message de la communauté et donc au
niveau des adultes et à cet exercice
d'abord à que les parents comprennent
exactement là où on en est un l'objectif
ultime qui est justement cette unité
cette réconciliation du peuple gronder
aussi leur dire que tous les autres
moteurs sont pas des criminels
ils doivent voir un humain comme
quelqu'un qui n'est bon comme jean
jacques est le seul a dit l'homme n'est
bon c'est la société qui est le coran ou
pour la famille ou zima l'art est un
baume sur les blessures du passé qui
leur permet d'avancer sans jamais
oublier ici florence guaino radio canada
ottawa
[Musique]